it's just a matter of time before it
happens some catastrophic event that
wipes out a large percentage of the
Earth's population and forces the human
race to reset maybe one of the thirty
thousand near-earth objects being
tracked by NASA finally hits the Earth
causing an Extinction event on par with
what wiped out the dinosaurs or Earth's
poles finally shift and without its
magnetic field the planet is exposed to
the raw destructive power of the sun's
radiation or maybe on his deathbed a
dictator decides to go out in a blaze of
glory and launches his entire nuclear
Arsenal it's just a matter of time
before one of these or one of another
dozen doomsday scenarios plays out and
when that happens world leaders like the
president of the United States and vice
president will be immediately taken to
underground facilities designed for this
event key members of Congress and the
military will also be taken to secure
locations but what about civilians there
are facilities around the world designed
to house many thousands of people but
who get saved while the rest of us are
left behind who makes that decision and
where are these facilities well I don't
know where VIPs go if they live in
Europe or Asia or Australia but in the
United States those Chosen Few they go
to Denver
foreign
the Mysteries surrounding the Denver
International Airport began before it
was even built a new airport was
something Denver didn't really need and
couldn't afford Stapleton airport was
conveniently located and could easily
handle the traffic in fact in the early
1990s Stapleton airport was expanded yet
a decision was made to decommission
Stapleton and build a brand new airport
25 miles outside the city in the middle
of nowhere with only one Road in or out
so plans were made bids were taken
contractors were hired and the problems
began when Dia opened on February 28
1995 construction was 16 months behind
schedule and two billion dollars over
budget the final cost of the airport was
4.8 billion dollars almost double the
original estimate the airport itself
sits on a 53 square mile complex twice
the size of Manhattan this is almost
twice as large as the next biggest U.S
airport being that at the time it was
only the 20th busiest airport in the
country this amount of construction and
money spent seems like Overkill unless
the construction project includes
something more than just an airport and
that's when people started noticing
things about Dia that didn't add up
construction workers themselves were
confused contractors were hired fired
and hired again nobody seemed to know
why teams knew what they were working on
but very few people knew the full scope
of the project
a complex network of tunnels was built
underneath the airport officially this
is six levels but some workers said it's
deeper than this though nobody can say
for sure 5300 miles of fiber optics were
installed for communication now that's
enough cable to go from New York to LA
and back a fueling system was built that
can pump 1 000 gallons of jet fuel per
minute this is way overkill for a
commercial Airport runway 16r 34l is
almost three miles long the longest
runway in the country this is also
overkill for a commercial airport unless
you're planning to land even bigger
planes and lots of them all airports are
surrounded by barbed wire for safety but
the barbs face outward to keep people
out for some reason at Denver Airport
the barbed wire was installed the wrong
way it's designed to keep people in five
large buildings were built and after
they were completed they were covered up
the official report is they were built
in the wrong place these buildings were
range from Seven stories to 15 stories
tall but rather than demolish them they
buried them that's very suspicious also
suspicious is the 40-foot wide tunnel
that was built to connect these buried
buildings to the rest of the facility
110 million cubic yards of Earth had
been moved for the underground structure
way more than required for comparison
that's about one-third the amount of
Earth moved to dig the entire Panama
Canal so people did the math that would
be enough Earth to account for a tunnel
to another facility like Cheyenne
Mountain Complex near Colorado Springs
Cheyenne is a bunker that in case of
nuclear war will serve as a major
command and control center for the
United States military many more
construction anomalies were noticed by
workers on the project but nobody had
enough information to connect the dots
as to who would be building a massive
underground facility and for what
purpose but as various parts of the
airport were completed hints of
something sinister started to appear for
example when the runways were completed
people took notice that from the air
they form the shape of a swastika
concern locals suspected that Denver
International might be something more
than just an airport so when Dia finally
opened people looked for clues that
might indicate that it was built by a
secret group with a secret agenda and
the clues are everywhere
[Music]
when Denver International Airport
finally opened it didn't take long for
people to realize this place was unusual
the first thing you see when you arrive
on the property before you even enter
the building is the blue Mustang this is
a 32 foot tall 9 000 pound statue with
visible red veins and glowing red eyes I
looked and
Pale Horse
is right his name was death and Hell
Followed With Him
Revelation six I know it's revelation
some people believe the statue
symbolizes the fourth horse of the
Apocalypse so people started calling him
Lucifer and believed that he was cursed
now this might sound silly but Lucifer
killed his creator whoa what the artist
Luis Jimenez was killed in a freak
accident when a piece of the horse fell
off and severed an artery in luis's leg
but the creepier artwork is inside the
airport Denver must be the only airport
in the world that features gargoyles in
the baggage area
well the artist Terry Allen said they're
there as protectors and throughout
history gargoyles were placed on
buildings to scare away evil spirits and
scare away human children right and even
scarier are the murals painted around
the airport like this one what is this
see this is in the airport this is the
first of four murals by artist Leo
tanguma this Called Peace and harmony
with nature and we've got children in
coffins extinct animals a forest on fire
in the back a city Burns a child holds a
Mayan tablet depicting at the end of the
world yeah nothing says have a great
flight like dead people in coffins yeah
this isn't the kind of artwork you want
to see if you're a nervous flyer waiting
on your connecting flight well here's
another mural yeah come on you're making
this up nope like the runways and the
murals there are references to Nazi
Germany all over the place here we have
a Nazi wearing a gas mask holding a
rifle and slicing through a city with a
sword at the end of the sword a dead dub
signifying the death of Peace there are
children lying in the rubble on the left
citizens flee the city a mother cries
while cradling the corpse of her dead
child
in the lower right is a poem written by
a child who died in a Nazi concentration
camp
that is a terrible idea to put these
pitches up in a place where weed is
legal I know talk about a harsh Buzz now
to be fair there is a second half of
this painting here we see children from
every culture in the world carrying
weapons and the flags of countries to
this little German boy in the center
so all these countries disarm and
surrender their Flags to the little
blonde haired blue-eyed German boy yeah
exactly and nobody sees a problem with
this I guess not pillow this is a
picture on a one-world government and a
new world order oh you're not the first
one to make that connection well of
course not not everyone's a sheep so
people started looking for Clues as to
who is really behind the airport project
here's a clue that's extremely obvious
this is the airport dedication plaque
Freemasons of course right the Masons
were involved in the dedication but look
at the name under the date New World
Airport Commission Now if you're already
worried that a shadow government is
trying to implement the new world order
this is pretty unsettling and on the
nose nobody had heard of the New World
Airport commission what do they do and
why are they involved with the airport
and with the Masons and most importantly
who is behind this secret group
naturally concerned citizens looked into
the organization and what did they find
they found that the New World Airport
commission doesn't exist
ever since civilization emerged there
have been people trying to control it
Julius Caesar Alexander the Great Attila
the Hun Napoleon Hitler Kanye West well
aside from Kanye these were dictators
tyrants who crushed dissent and
brutalized their enemies they ruled
through cruelty and fear the people
behind the New World Order don't operate
openly they operate in the shadows and
pull the strings of the world's leaders
in the Middle Ages this group was
suspected to be the Templar knights in
the late 18th century there was a secret
society called the order of the
Illuminati which you probably heard of
there are other secret societies rumored
to be this ruling Elite but no secret
society comes up more in the discussion
of the New World Order than the
Freemasons the Masons need their own
video and if you'd like to see that
email me or let me know in the comments
but the gist is this the Masons project
a public image of piety and charity but
secretly they have a hidden political
agenda to bring about a one world
government ruled only by Masons and you
can see symbols of the Masons everywhere
if you look the Mason's Eye of
Providence is on U.S currency on the
Capstone at Denver International Airport
is the compass and square even though
the airport opened on February 28 1995
the Capstone was placed on March 19 1994
and if you add up 319 1994 you get the
number 33. the number 33 is very
significant in Freemasonry it's the
highest degree a Mason can achieve and
that number is everywhere again the
Masons need their own video how about
the mural with the Nazi that's a very
unusual sword for a soldier unless
you're familiar with the ancient Arabic
order of the Nobles of the Mystic Shrine
that's a masonic order known as the
Shriners and this is their symbol
and the Gargoyles in the baggage area
they're coming out of Samsonite
suitcases Samsonite is an anagram for
Mason's sight yo come on
well the location of the Capstone is in
the Great Hall of the airport Masons
call their meeting room the Great Hall
and there are a lot of suspicions about
the Capstone itself it's also a time
capsule set to be opened in 2094. what's
in a gas mask is an MREs well not
everyone agrees some people think it's a
bomb others think it's an entrance to an
underground bunker that can be opened by
touching the Braille plaque in a
specific way like a keypad Mason's
passing through the airport have been
seen holding their membership cards next
to it to see if it opens now officially
the Time Capsule contains a newspaper
baseballs from Coors Field coins from
the Denver Mint and a pair of Mayor
Wellington sneakers wait wait
through his dirty sneakers in a hole
Yeah I guess he thought that was a good
idea can you imagine with dirty sneak of
funk smells like after 100 years I'm
trying not to by the way the mayor was a
Mason of course he was a part of the New
World Order slash One World Government
plan is population reduction but how
exactly will they reduce the population
well the answer to that question is
right under our feet
[Music]
foreign
the New World Order the Masons the
Illuminati yep the Bilderberg Group yep
Bohemian Club nobody really knows but
when the group emerges to put the entire
planet under a single dictatorship
they'll need a few methods to get
everyone to comply they'll Implement
Mass surveillance but tell us it's for
protection
um they'll consolidate mainstream media
into a small handful of corporations
that will publish propaganda as an
official narrative and censor anyone who
disagrees they'll disarm the population
eliminate religion take over education
from preschool to University
indoctrinating young people with their
narrative but they you know they'll need
to establish a single currency to do
this they'll need to crash the current
banking system so the general population
loses faith and places their money in
accounts protected and managed by the
state okay enough what all this is
already happening well that depends on
your point of view well my point of view
is the truth well don't be a sheep let's
say that eventually all this comes to
pass
it will be much easier to control people
if there are fewer people to control so
when the New World Order is finally
implemented depopulation will be part of
that plan but you can't send soldiers
out to knock off the population it
wouldn't work they won't turn on their
own people so it has to be done secretly
in a way that doesn't arouse suspicion
according to the New World Order Plan
this could be done with say a global
pandemic I know what you're thinking
this also happened but that wasn't
caused by the Illuminati
let's go back to the gas mask mural
obviously this depicts some kind of
chemical warfare well on the floor near
the mural is this
auag in a mining cart the official
statement is this represents silver and
gold it's to honor the miners who helped
build the city of Denver but some point
until more Sinister interpretation auag
is also the abbreviation for the
Australia antigen a highly contagious
and deadly toxin that attacks the liver
once Unleashed on the world the
population will beg the state for help
they'll surrender every freedom they
have to Simply feel safe then the secret
powerful group can decide who lives and
who dies they'll create a vaccine but
won't allow everyone to access it people
deemed undesirable will simply be
allowed to succumb to illness while the
people deemed desirable will not only
have access to this vaccine they'll be
forced to take it again for their own
protection look if you don't see it by
now I don't know what to tell you come
on that's not what happened the past few
years hello it's
that's pretty scary to think about but
the Denver Airport holds Secrets even
darker than this and to learn about
those secrets we have to go underground
[Music]
millions of cubic feet of Earth removed
level upon level of tunnels hundreds of
feet down large buildings constructed
and then for some reason buried the
project did go way over budget but not
if that money was used to construct a
secret underground facility and when the
airport project went over budget the
government stepped in and bailed it out
there is a vast tunnel system under the
airport this is a fact it was built for
a state-of-the-art baggage handling
system allegedly no it was
but but it didn't work very well so
despite it costing a hundred million
dollars it was abandoned that's just
like the buildings that were built and
abandoned yep the year the airport
opened Phil Schneider came forward and
blew the whistle on the project Phil was
an engineer who worked on secret
government programs including
underground bunkers and this is
confirmed there are publicly available
records that show Phil Schneider worked
as a government contractor for years
well Phil Schneider and other
contractors who worked on the airport
have said the underground area isn't six
levels deep as is commonly known but
actually eight levels deep and this
lower area is used as a military base
and covers an area of about four and a
half square miles now people have
questioned why underground tunnels made
of concrete would need so many
sprinklers along the ceiling this is
supposed to be not just for water but to
give authorities the ability to pump gas
into the common areas gas to
incapacitate people or infect people
with something like the Australian
antigen in fact it's been said that FEMA
has a large area underground designed as
a camp for political enemies and
dissenters and the rumors continue
there's allegedly an underground base
where UFOs are kept for reverse
engineering some people call the Denver
Airport Area 52 but the most disturbing
rumor is that deep under the airport is
the headquarters of a race of humanoid
creatures who plan on enslaving the
entire human race not only do these
creatures use humans for labor they
breed them for food
kind of creatures are we talking about
uh that's not important who's eating
people down here is it crazy is it the
gray aliens no it's not the grace
the tall white aliens nope the serpo
aliens I thought the aliens from planet
Circle were vegetarian no the creatures
living down there aren't aliens
is it it is lizard people
people yep the secret cabal planning to
take over the world are not the Masons
or the Illuminati they're reptilian
humanoids not long after revealing this
information about the airport Phil
Schneider took his own life oh here we
go again I know and if you check our
episode on Dulce base we cover the
mysterious circumstances around Phil
Schneider's death we do know the last
time Phil Schneider spoke in public
about this was 1995 and at the end of
the talk he said at least 12 of his
friends died mysteriously within the
last few years he felt like he was being
watched and feared for his life he
specifically said that if he turns up
dead no matter what the official Reports
say he was killed and maybe this is all
coincidence but he said these things at
a talk he was giving in Denver well I
don't believe in coincidences neither do
I
Denver airport conspiracy theories have
been around since before the airport was
built which is why I was surprised so
many of you wanted me to cover it but
old story or not it's still one of my
favorites
but is it true well let's explain what
we can and then we'll see what's left
people who cover the story say that
Denver didn't need another airport that
Stapleton was fine well it wasn't it was
congested and inefficient yes it was
convenient to get to because it was
downtown but it wasn't great for the
people who lived and worked downtown
airports are noisy so Dia was built
outside the city because there was cheap
flat land away from residential areas
now the shape of the runway I guess it
looks like a swastika but not a very
good one the runways are laid out this
way so planes can land from any
direction depending on the weather the
barbed wire is one of my favorite little
tidbits the barbed wire is designed to
keep people in that's it's just so
ominous but it's not true the barbs are
vertical they don't face one way or the
other now videos and articles about the
Denver Airport will say that the New
World Airport commission doesn't exist
now I thought the same thing for years
but it did exist it was a temporary
committee formed to plan the ceremony
around the opening of the airport but it
will concede that choosing that name was
a terrible idea now the Masonic symbol
is on the Capstone because well the
Masons paid for it now they may be
planning a world takeover someday but in
the meanwhile Masons are pretty generous
auag is gold and silver that's all there
is to it but it could also be I know it
could be the Australian antigen I know
it could but the Australia antigen is
just a protein that indicates a patient
has Hepatitis B a hepatitis B is pretty
bad but it does have a 95 survival rate
still exposure to just the antigen
wouldn't hurt you in fact the Australia
antigen was used to create a vaccine for
Hepatitis B the doctor who discovered it
actually won the Nobel Prize for this
now the murals are weird no doubt the
artist wanted to honor his Heritage as a
Chicano descended from the Maya he was
trying to portray a message of peace and
he tried me but he failed well that's a
matter of taste but yeah they were
pretty disturbing the murals have since
been removed and are now in storage now
things like the murals the horse the
Gargoyles these are all done by local
artists with no direction from the
airport and I don't think the
administrators at the airport were
trying to give hints about something
sinister but I will say they had
terrible taste in art now the sprinklers
in the tunnels they're not there to
spray citizens with gas they're there
because of fire code concrete doesn't
burn but plenty of other things down
there would the five buried buildings I
can't find any evidence that they ever
existed now I'm not saying they didn't
I'm just telling you I couldn't find
anything but honestly I hope they exist
because it just makes the story that
much more fun as for Phil Schneider he
did die under mysterious circumstances
and I go into it in more detail in the
Dulce base episode but in a nutshell
Phil was mentally distraught and made up
a lot of his stories and in that episode
I prove it I can't say that he lied
about everything but he did lie about
some things and when you do that we have
to question everything you say his death
was weird though now if there are secret
tunnels down there I'm not sure we would
know about them so we can't completely
discount the idea as you know in case of
nuclear war or some disaster the
president is taken to a bunker for Cog
protocols also known as continuity of
government these bunkers are fortresses
where elected leaders can coordinate
military response and manage the entire
country on the East Coast this bunker is
Mount Weather Virginia on the west coast
it's Cheyenne Mountain about a hundred
miles south of Denver Airport
fine but there's something strange in
2011 the comet elenin was headed toward
Earth it was expected to miss us which
it did but it had just been discovered
so NASA couldn't be sure at the time
elenin was between three and four miles
wide almost as big as the rock that
wiped out the dinosaurs so President
Obama was rushed to a secret facility
but not Cheyenne Mountain as his
protocol instead the president was taken
100 miles north of Cheyenne he was taken
to Denver Airport
the Denver Airport is a difficult
conspiracy to research not for lack of
information there's plenty of that it's
the way the information is presented
that irritates me it's condescending if
you believe any of these theories you're
a kook you're crazy even the airport
itself does this whatever they do any
work inside the airport they put up
signs of lizard people and aliens and
memes of tinfoil hats the signs say
they're building gargoyle breeding
grounds and preparing for the end of the
world and they find this all very funny
they even installed a talking gargoyle
who spits out one-liners welcome to
Illuminati headquarters I mean Denver
International Airport did you have to
buy an extra seat for your hat sir sir
are you stealing a desk
sir you have resting confused face
hey look those jokes aren't that strong
but when you haven't come out of some
creature's mouth you can get away with
it I'm aware anyway a spokesman for the
airport said this we have a CEO William
braces the conspiracy ideas we decided a
few years ago that rather than fight all
of this and try to convince everybody
there's nothing really going on let's
have some fun with it well it's nice
they're having fun but if you have
questions about the airport they're not
laughing with you they're laughing at
you and people took notice some even
responded to that statement online
instead of answering all the questions
about the Freemason Time Capsule the
death horse you have outside murals of
Slaughter on your walls underground
tunnels Etc you make of course a
gargoyle making fun of everything comedy
is the best way to deflect real
questions good job the shiba will fall
right into your trap
hahaha don't pay attention to the man
behind the curtain folks see how funny
this demonic statue is aren't the
satanic Global elitists so hilarious
just keep laughing stay distracted
nothing to see underneath this airport
nothing at all
the question that always comes up is the
underground area the tunnels and the
answer is always the same whether it's
an official response from the
government-run airport or from Snopes or
from YouTubers who are much more
intelligent than we are they say there's
no way anyone can be down there and go
unnoticed a thousand people work under
the airport every day they would see
something obviously well they never
heard of The Greenbrier hotel located
about five hours away from Washington DC
it's an upscale Resort that's been
visited by 26 U.S presidents and
European Royals in the 1950s the hotel
was going through Renovations so the US
government piggybacked on the renovation
project and installed a bunker under the
hotel that sounds familiar doesn't it
and they didn't install a little safe
room they built a 112
000 square foot bunker under that hotel
it has 25 ton blast doors a power plant
cafeteria a hospital with labs and a
pharmacy it can house 1100 people and
was the destination for all of Congress
in case of an emergency
and for 30 years nobody knew it was
there not even hotel workers in 1992 The
Washington Post exposed the facility and
in 1995 the government stopped using it
coincidentally that's the same year that
the Denver Airport opened the Greenbrier
bunker had staff working there the
entire time right under everyone's nose
some parts of it weren't even
underground and that was in a busy Hotel
the area under the Denver Airport is
huge so big there are emergency phones
for people who get lost to say that you
can't be fooled by a secret government
project is nonsense it's arrogant and
it's annoying but this is something
we're seeing more and more these past
few years if you dare to question the
narrative coming out of the government
or the mainstream media right if you
question them you're labeled a
conspiracy theorist you're marginalized
and mocked publicly for most people
that's enough to shut them up why speak
up if you're going to be attacked on
Twitter it's not worth it if you do
speak up well then they just censor you
but every once in a while conspiracies
turn out to be true that's why I don't
condescend to you that's why I don't
talk down to people who believe I don't
believe every story I cover here I don't
believe most of them but I still want to
find the truth if I can and there have
been some stories that I couldn't debunk
and when that happens I'm honest with
you about it and if I think about the
past six or seven years I can rattle off
six off the top of my head six quote
unquote conspiracies that if you talked
about them would get you banned on
social media but they turned out to be
true such as no I can't name them even
though they're true you still can't
discuss them at least not on certain
platforms but there are places online
where you can talk about Fringe topics
and I encourage you to do it I also
encourage you to discuss these things
with your friends and neighbors family
co-workers if they're condescending to
you don't take it personally they're
brainwashed they'll eat whatever
mainstream media library
I like it and isn't that ironic because
they look down on those of us who
question authority they try to cancel
those those of us who call out Lies when
we see them but when conspiracies turn
out to be true and from time to time
they do it will be us who stands between
the Skeptics and the tyrants trying to
take their freedom and When the Smoke
Clears and the dust settles and we know
everyone is safe I'll be the first one
to say I told you
foreign
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is AJ you know
hecklefish hi there hello this has been
the Wi-Fi if you had fun or learned
anything do us a favor and like comment
subscribe share that stuff really helps
and like most topics we cover on this
channel today's topic was recommended by
you by thousands of you and if there's a
story that you'd like to see her learn
more about go to the yfiles.com tips and
special thanks to our patrons who make
all this possible we couldn't do this
without you and if you'd like to be part
of an amazing Community check out our
Discord it's free but if you'd like to
support the channel consider becoming a
member on patreon or grab something from
the Wi-Fi store show them the new don't
be a sheep bug I really don't know them
show them the other side
hey hey
proud of this one this one it should be
that's gonna do it until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
foreign